blond cendré le blond platine c'est plus
joli préfecture on attend que cyril
valide de revenus et avant de passer le
concours
[Musique]
le sort des régals toi ou la wii
bye bye
[Musique]
mais c'est quoi même si on est exclusive
mon choix de m6 bande de bouffons bah
casse toi vas avoir l'autocar de la
villardière ok ils seront blessés
[Musique]
avec le cas milliards le e-vote elana
qui danse nue sur le ponton elles sont
là il y en a une ah ouais et franchit de
paillettes
[Musique]
alors je vous dis moi on sait qu'il aura
pas facilement
je fais un livre à la journée dans le
cantal avant de me déguiser et avant de
me travestir la part également passé du
temps depuis danger l'entraîneur de
l'inter de milan
huawei ça c'est la reine de saba dire
que la halle et non
[Musique]